O
TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT.
>> Tucker: WELCOME BACK.
NOT A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE WORKING
RIGHT NOW IN THE UNITED STATES.
THAT'S A BIG CHANGE.
THAT'S WHY MAYBE YOU HAVE TO USE
THE DRIVE-THRU BECAUSE NO ONE IS
INSIDE THE RESTAURANT BUT NOT
ONLY IS THE WAY WE WORK CHANGING
OUR ATTITUDES TOWARDS WORK ARE
CHANGING AND A LOT OF
SIGNIFICANT ATTEMPT FOR WORK.
MICRO-SPENT A LIFE THINKING
ABOUT WORK AND HOST OF HOW
AMERICA WORKS AND JOINS US ON
THE SET OF PATRIOT AWARDS.
THE LONG TIME THE IMMORTAL HOST
OF DIRTY JOBS.
OUR MOST FREQUENT AND POPULAR
GUEST.
THANK YOU FOR COMING BACK.
YOU HAVE NOTICED THE CHANGE IN
ATTITUDE TOWARDS WORK.
SOME PEOPLE SORT OF MOCKING THE
IDEA OF WORK.
WHAT'S YOUR RESPONSE TO THAT?
>> YEAH, SO I'M A -- I'M WRONG
AS MUCH AS I AM RIGHT.
FOR THAT REASON I HATE TO SAY I
TOLD YOU SO OUT LOUD EVER.
FOR 15 YEARS MY FOUNDATION AS
BEEN TALKING ABOUT A SLOW SORT
OF UNRAVELING THAT WE LOOSELY
CALL WORK ETHIC, WHATEVER THAT
MEANS AND NOW BETWEEN NICK
EVERST AT'S WORK, AN ECONOMIST
THAT DRILLED DOWN AND LAST WEEK
THERE WAS AN ARTICLE IN THE NEW
YORK TYPES CALLED HOW TO COMBAT
THE ASSAULT ON MODERN WORK.
I THOUGHT IT WAS GOING TO BE AN
ARTICLE ABOUT COAL MINERS OR
CRAB IF I RECOLLECTERMEN OR THE
REAL TOUGH JOB WHERE IT'S
DANGEROUS AND IT WASN'T.
IT'S AN ARTICLE OF PAPER CUT TO
NONEXISTENT PET BEREAVEMENT
POLICIES AND I'M NOT MAKING IT
UP.
WE ARE IN A PLACE WHERE
7 MILLION ABLE-BODIED MEN ARE
NOT ONLY NOT WORKING, BETWEEN
THE AGES OF 25 AND 40 -- >>
Tucker: 7 MILLION?
>> 7 MILLION ABLED BODIED MEN
ARE NOT WORMING OR LOOKING FOR A
JOB.
THAT'S NEVER HAPPENED IN
PEACETIME.
EVER.
AND ECONOMISTS LIKE NICK
EVERSTAT TAKE A DIM VIEW AND
THEY'RE WORRIED AND TRYING TO
INJECT THAT INTO THE
CONVERSATION AT A TIME WHEN
WE'RE STILL LOOKING AT THE
UNEMPLOYMENT NUMBER AS THE TRUE
HARBINGER OF WHAT'S GOING ON.
IT'S NOT.
IN HIS VIEW, IT'S THE DEPRESSION
ERA ARTIFACT.
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE WRONG
THING.
WE'RE LOOKING AT MOTT WHAT IT
MEANS TO HAVE A BUNCH OF PEOPLE
UNEMPLOYED BUT WHAT DOES IT MEAN
TO HAVE A BUNCH OF OPPORTUNITY
THAT NOBODY GIVES A DAM ABOUT?
THAT'S A DIFFERENT CONVERSATION.
IT'S COMPLICATED TO HAVE BECAUSE
WHILE THAT DYNAMIC IS CLEAR AND
PRESENT, SO TOO IS THE FACT THAT
A LOT OF BIG COMPANIES IN
SILICON VALLEY WILL LAY OFF A
LOT OF PEOPLE AND YOU'LL HAVE A
BUNCH OF PEOPLE NOT TRAINED FOR
THE JOBS THAT DO EXIST SORT OF
COMPETING WITH PEOPLE WHO HAVE
AFFIRMATIVELY TAKEN THEMSELVES
OUT OF THE WORK FORCE ENTIRELY
AND WHO, FINAL POINT, I ASKED
NICK, WHAT ARE THEY DOING?
WHAT ARE THEY DOING WITH THEIR
TIME?
THESE ABLE-BODIED MEN.
>> Tucker: GOOD QUESTION.
>> ON AVERAGE OVER 2,000 HOURS A
YEAR ON SCREENS.
>> Tucker: THEY'RE TOTALLY
HYPNOTIZED BY THE DIGITAL WORLD.
>> THEY'RE OUT.
THEY'RE OUT.
>> Tucker: AT SOME POINT, THE
PILOT SHORTAGE IS ONE THING
THAT'S WELL KNOWN WHEN IT'S HARD
TO GET YOUR PLANE ON TIME OR
COST IS GOING UP BECAUSE THERE'S
NOT ENOUGH PILOTS BUT TRUE FOR A
LOT OF DIFFERENT JOBS.
WHEN DOES IT START TO GRIND TO A
HALT?
>> PILOTS GET THE PRESS BECAUSE
IT'S THE PILOT.
BUT WHEN YOU REALLY FOLLOW THE
DELAYS DOWN, YOU'LL FIND IT IN
THE MECHANICS, YOU'LL FIND IN
THE FLIGHT ATTENDIDN'TS.
HOW MANY AIRPORTS DID YOU HAVE
WHEN THE CREW COULDN'T MAKE IT
TO THE NEXT PLANE?
IT'S BECAUSE THEY'RE WORKING
WITH 70% OF THE WORK FORCE THEY
HAD THREE YEARS AGO.
YOU KNOW, 4 MILLION FEWER PEOPLE
ARE IN THE WORK FORCE TODAY THAN
BEFORE THE LOCKDOWNS AND
4 MILLION MORE JOBS HAVE OPENED
UP.
IT'S ALMOST A PERFECT MIRROR
IMAGE AND THE REFLECTION IS KIND
OF HIDEOUS.
>> IT'S JUST SAD.
>> Tucker: WORK IS MEANING.
AS YOU HAVE SPENT YOUR LIFE
SH